class of 2019 during your time here you
have seen our campus go through
transformative changes the expansion of
our coin University Center and its
infamous stone cages a new Scott Hall
Pepper quad countless classroom
renovations even Wien Hall got an
upgrade at la prima but of course to
keep you from making more improvements
we had to install a camera in the self
service elevator of Wien Hall sorry to
ruin your fun you each have left an
indelible mark on this community you
learned deeply and daily inside and
outside the classroom you demonstrated
what interdisciplinary learning and
discovery in the 21st century looks like
and you were there for each other during
the times of celebration and also during
times of loss both on our campus and in
the broader community after the tragedy
at tree of life through your acts of
empathy and inclusion you helped to
shine a bright light through moments of
darkness by surrounding each other and
comfort you reaffirmed our commitment to
our core values of inclusion respect and
compassion and you also illuminated ways
our community could do better in
prioritizing a healthy mind body and
spirit which is the foundation of the
CMU experience from mentoring local high
school students in financial literacy to
using the power of the Arts to connect
with the homeless in community in
Pittsburgh to charter planes to aid
hurricane victims in Puerto Rico
your Community Engagement brought
awareness to important issues and made a
difference you brought passion and
thoughtfulness to everything you did
whether he was building an amusement
park ride in skeebo gym performing in
sold-out performance of cabaret
designing and leading StuCo classes on
the cultural meaning of Marvel films and
principles of racecar engineering and so
on
or conducting research at the
intersection of Technology and humanity
such as writing programming languages
for blockchain and exploring novel
approaches for bio fabricating organs
listen I even have to admire the
diligence you showed in campaigning to
close our campus during the polar vortex
[Applause]
if family members are wondering yes it
did work and by the way students you're
welcome you also try to rename carnival
too far novel and and that did not work
through your example you made a
community others want to join you were
instrumental in making our Welcome
Center a thriving hub on campus and
drawing the largest number of
application in the university's history
[Applause]
the class of 2019 I want to thank you
for making CMU better now it is your
time to unleash your extraordinary
energy and skills on the vast
opportunities ahead of you before we
confer your degrees it is tradition for
the president to deliver a charge to
graduates I'll keep it short one final
set of instructions for how to maximize
the power of your newly minted CMU
degrees the incomparable CMU professor
and Nobel laureate herb Simon once said
we're not spectres of spectators of the
future we're actors of the future you
may be wondering how exactly you become
an actor of the future well first of all
listen to Leslie while I don't have all
the answers I want to offer three
guiding principles to help you embrace
professor Simon's philosophy first be
relentless in your pursuit of knowledge
being educated doesn't simply mean
getting a degree and then sitting back
rather it requires that you constantly
rekindle the fires of your curiosity and
stay engaged in the evolution of new
ideas don't be afraid to expand your
horizons when the landscape shifts
beneath you make the world your
classroom your canvas your laboratory
your stage ii seek out perspectives
other than your own by exploring
different identities and experiences you
will create better ideas and stronger
solutions along the way you will
encounter ideas that will challenge you
even if you consider those ideas wrong
or perhaps offensive the remedy is not
less conversation but more conversation
ideas are not defeated by suppression
they are defeated by better more
persuasive ideas
I urge you to embrace and defend the
freedom free expression of ideas freedom
of expression is the foundation of our
democracy my third and last piece of
advice is perhaps the most important of
all and it may in fact surprise you
embrace empathy compassion and respect
as the foundation of your life today you
celebrate the culmination of many years
of hard work and determination continue
to create opportunities for yourself
of course but at the same time be
mindful of the connections that link us
to one another think about all the
people who have contributed to your
success today directly or indirectly
whether the professors coaches advisors
friends family members and so on
remember to enrich the lives of others
in the same way and create opportunities
for those who follow you class of 2019
you all possess the training and
intellect to be impactful actors of the
future
I am truly excited for you and I am
excited for the future which you hold in
your hands thank you for allowing me to
share this moment with you and on behalf
of the entire CMU community
congratulations class of 2019
[Applause]